before acting you're a professional  skateboarder  which i totally see so wait here's some  footage of you let's watch  oh my gosh now  i would be breaking all kinds of stuff  with  that like you're holding something no  how long have you been skating  uh so i've been skating since i was  around 10 or 11 years old  oh my gosh is it is it a thing that like  your parents were into like was your dad  into it or something oh no no no no  no no my mom my mom and pops couldn't  stand me skating  so wait were your parents more into you  skateboarding or acting because i know  you said they didn't like you  skateboarding but were they  super stoked about you acting yeah well  i mean  well when i made my first check skating  that's when my pops  and my mom got really stoked on it but  then with  acting you know it wasn't too dangerous  right so  it was just it was cherry right off the  bat they're into it  they were super supportive and uh  yeah they were more supportive about  acting at first